a freak Ocampa welcome to another the
daily programmer webseries video the
problem today we're going to talk about
is called talking clock which is number
three to one let's go ahead and look at
the subreddit and read through it
alright so for this problem the
description says no more hiding from
your alarm clock you decide you want
your computer to keep you updated from
time to time so you're never late again
a talking clock takes a 24 hour time and
translates it into words so for the
input we're given this type of string so
military time for instance we have the
string 28 : 29 which would be 8 29 and
then our goal is to take that input
string in to print out its string
representations so in this case 2029
should print out its 829 p.m. and then 4
0 0 if you print out its 12 a.m. so from
reading the description just looking at
the input data in the output data it
should be pretty straightforward as to
what we're trying to do so let's start
breaking this down in tempo mania on the
white board alright so let's look at a
single example here where we have 22 :
35 and the first thing that comes to
mind is when you have something like
this you need to kind of process it from
you know the hours and the minutes it's
useful to kind of extract your hours
separate from your minutes so you can go
ahead and split this string on the colon
which will give you an array of 22 and
35 as string form and then you can
convert those to integers using the
Partizan method or you know math the
array and pass it apart and function but
regardless when you end up with 22 and
35 we're going to be using these to kind
of generate these three subproblems so
if you were to look at the main problem
that we're trying to solve there are
three different things you kind of have
to do and you could do this separately
so the first one is how do you print out
the hour so that's like how you print
out one o'clock two o'clock three
o'clock to 12 o'clock how do you print
out the minute is so problem 2 which
will be the hardest and we'll save that
one for last and that would be like how
do you print out if it's zero five zero
five in this case thirty five how do you
print out 35 AM or PM and then the third
sub problem is how do you print out AM
or PM and again since this military time
zero is 12 a.m. 12 is 12 noon which is
12 p.m. and then 23 would be a
11 p.m. so out of these three
sub-problem let's go ahead and start
with the easiest one which would be
print a.m. / p.m. so to do that this one
should be pretty straightforward so if
you were to take the our representation
here so 22
how would you check if this is in the
afternoon or if this is in the morning
like a.m. well basically if it's less
than 12 we know that should be a.m.
otherwise it should be p.m. so in this
case 22 would be 10 o'clock at night so
we can just use this if statements to
determine if it's amber p.m. and that's
pretty straightforward so in this case
we're going to say it's p.m. go ahead
and write p.m. at the end of your string
and see that for later so we solved the
first sub problem which is Hedy to
determine if it's a more p.m. pretty
straightforward and then let's move on
to sub problem 1 it's how do you print
out the hour so to do this first we want
to declare some type of structure so you
can divert the number that we have as
the input and determine that the string
it needs to be out put it right so over
here I went ahead and defined an array
which represents the different hours we
can print out so 12 1 2 3 4 all the way
to 11 o'clock and I'm mapping some index
to those so it turns out that you know
these are integers and they map pretty
well to the indexes of arrays so I went
ahead and just decided to choose an
array to kind of figure out the
conversion so to map let's say in number
22 to the corresponding number it needs
to be over in this hours array we could
simply just mod it by 12 which is the
number of hours that you have in each
segment of the day a.m. and p.m. so if
you do 22 mod 12 we're left with 10 and
if you use that index 10 and figure out
what it needs to be in this hours array
index 10 should point to the string 10
so in this case down here we could just
say you know print out hours of 22 mod
12 and that should give us index 10
which would then print out the string
ten I'll just go ahead and start this
with it's right and so if you were to do
something else such as instead of let's
say this was in twenty-two and I said
this is twelve we'd be left with the
index of zero which would give us 12 and
if the input was let's say zero we're
also going to get zero which is twelve
because you remember zero zero is 12:00
a.m. which again will work as we
intended to so that's how you do the
subproblem print hours pretty
straightforward as well just declare an
array or each index of the array points
to the string representation of that
index and then just mod your input hours
to by 12 to get whatever index you need
to print out so let's move on to the
last part of this problem which is the
harder part which is printing out the
ministering so to start off there's
there's a couple of different
subproblems the first step problem for
printing the minute is let's say it's a
number that's less than 10 right those
are single-digit numbers so in this case
let's say this is o 5 instead of 35 we
need to print out o 5 so again we can
still do like the same logic here but
instead of using an hours array we can
go ahead and just use a ones array and
the ones array same idea of the hours
array but instead of 0 through 11 we
have indexes 0 through 9 where 0 is a
blank string 1 is the string 1 etc until
9 we have the string 9 so in this
particular case how do you print out if
let's say we had a 5 as our input
how would you print out a 5 here right
so if it is less than 10 we know that we
need to use this ones array to kind of
figure out what the string needs to be
and again we could just take the digit
as our index and print it out here so in
this case we get Oh 5 here which would
be cast to 5 if we parse it as an INT
and then our index 5 would just print
out 5 and we can prefix with oh then
concatenate it with whatever that is
again I'll write out the first case
which is if M is less than 10 and again
the first case
and most of ten we just need to print
out single-digit the second case if M is
less than twenty we need to print out
the teens right so 13 14 15 11 12
whatever so let's go ahead and declare
another array called teens which we can
use to again map numbers from 10 to 19
using the same process so again this one
once we get M we're actually gonna have
to mod it by 10 so we can get what value
it is in this array so in this case if M
is let's say 15 if we mod that by chin
we'll get 5 and if we look up index 5
and this tins array or teens array 5
should equal the string 5 if we try it
with let's say 10 mod 10 we're going to
be left with 0 which will give us 10 is
our string if we mod it by 19 by 10
we're going to be left with index 9
which again over here 9 is 19 so we saw
sub-problem if M is less than 10
we set the subproblem if n is less than
20 now for the last sub problem is else
so otherwise it's greater than or equal
to 20 now in this case we need yet
another array which will be called our
kins array and what this array is used
for is printing out the tens digit so in
this case 35 we need to print out 30 and
then we also need to print out 5 so
taking that example let's just go ahead
and say okay well how do we print out 30
so we have this tens array over here
index is 0 through 5 we need to get
index 3 right the digit 3 will represent
30 down here so to do that we can just
do M divided by 10 and then floor that
and that should leave us with 3 in this
case in next 3 will give a sturdy
go ahead right it's 10:30 and then the
last part of this is we need to get the
ones digit so I can say em mod 10 in
this case 35 mod 10 will give us 5 and
if we were looked at up in the ones
array over here we should get the string
5 so if I were to just do that so we can
pronounce 5 here and that's basically
how you work out this problem in this
sub problem where if you were to print
out 35 we just use the ones array we use
a tens array you kind of connect
concatenate them together we can mod by
10 or divide by 10 to get the different
digits so divide by 10 gives us 3 mod by
10 gives us 5 look those up and then
print to my down here so finally the
single input 22 : 35 will give us the
output it's 10:35 p.m. hopefully this is
a good overview of how to break this
down into different subproblems and
again how to break in break down this
sub problem 2 which is print minute into
the different cases that we need to
handle there's probably a different way
to do this but I think this is the
easiest that comes to my mind all right
so again let's implement this in
JavaScript alright so start off with the
implementation I went ahead and declared
those 4 arrays that are used for mapping
the integer value to the string
representation so you see here we have a
capital ours array which has all the 12
to 11 we have the Capital One's array
which has all the different ones digit
so 1 2 3 4 5 7 8 9 we have two teams
array which is used for mapping all
those different cases where we have 10
through 19 and then finally we have the
tins array which is used for mapping the
tens digit of cases that are greater
than equal to 20 and then down here
which is go ahead and start with the use
case of 0 0 comma 0 0 and let's start
declaring the function called talk which
takes 8 time as an input parameter so
the first thing we want to do again is
take that time string and we go ahead
and split it pars the int and map it to
an array like say Const of H M is equal
to time we've split and then split it by
the colons and then map it to by the
pars int
function and then I'll go ahead and
return the empty string here just for
now so just to kind of see what's going
on here I'll print out hmm those both
print out zero so that's expected if I
were to change this to let's say 1 & 1
those both print out 1 & 1 so that's
working as intended so let's first start
with the first sub problem which is how
do you print out the our string so to do
that remember we have the hours array
which we can grab H from and then begin
to mod by 12 and then we could say Const
hour is equal to that and if I were to
print out our down here we see that it
prints out 12 so we just solved the
first sub problem which how do we print
out the hours and you see down here
we're printing out 12 which is expected
and then before we take a step forward
I'm just going to go ahead and just
print out or start working on an array
where we can say it's and then also pre
mount hours and I'm going to join those
with an empty string such is kind of
building up for a final string that
we're supposed to print hasn't our
output and then the second sub problem
is how do you print out the suffix of AM
and PM so again we can say Const suffix
is equal to and then we use a ternary
operator here say H less than 12 then we
need to print out a.m. otherwise we
print out p.m. and we can just go ahead
and put suffix into that final array
that we're returning so you see down
here at printing out it's 12 a.m. if we
change this to 12 it prints out its 12
p.m. so this is all working as intended
it's 11 p.m. works fine and now for the
third sub problem which is where we have
to have those different cases let's just
go ahead and declare a minute object and
then I'm going to go ahead and put that
here so we can print out whatever the
minute value is in the first case is if
M is less than 10 remember we need to
print out the ones arrays corresponding
mapping value right so we can say
minutes is equal to
one of em and I'll go ahead and change
this to 2301 it says it's 11:00 1:00
p.m. so I forgot to put the O here so
now it's printing out it's 1101 p.m. and
then go ahead and test out your edge
cases of 0-9 it's 11 o 9:00 p.m. so
that's working as intended by change
this the tin probably won't work as we
went to because it should print out its
11:10 p.m. and we haven't implemented
that case yet so let's move on to the
second case which is if M is less than
20 we need to set minute equal to and
then we could say the teens and then M
divided by 10 like we did on the example
go ahead and close off that curly brace
so now in this case that's working fine
so it's 11:10 p.m. if I change this to
19 it should pronounced 1119 p.m. so
again we just implement a case 1 which
is it is less than 10 case 2 for the
teens if it's less than 20 and then
finally we use the or finally we write
the last case which will be if it's
greater than equal to 20 so we could set
minute equal to and then first we need
to do the tens again we floor in divided
by 10 here and that will give us our
tins
string representation of the tens digit
and then followed by space we can do
grab the ones array pass it in mod 10
and that will give us the one string are
the ones digit string representation and
then we can test that out here if you
put 23 20 it says it's 11:20 p.m. so
that's good
it's 11:29 p.m. when we change this to
29 change it to 59 its 11:59 p.m. so
basically we've implemented the same
solution that we worked on the
whiteboard and kind of as a recap we
declared those four arrays and we're
using those arrays to kind of determine
what the string value should be based on
the integer values and we use the
index for that mapping alright so that
wraps up the implementation of the
talking clock problem again if you liked
this tutorial be sure to like the video
and subscribe to free code camp below
all right thanks for watching